well the Republican who invented his
entire backstory including his religion
education and work history is now
admitting that he did it but he says
listen none of it was a crime I didn't
commit any crime and I plan to be a
member of the U.S House of
Representatives we're talking of course
about George Santos the New York Post
scored an interview with Santos and they
call it liar representative elect George
Santos admits fabricating key details of
his bio I am not a criminal he said
uh this controversy will not deter me
from having good legislative success I
will be effective I will be good he says
uh my sins here are embellishing my
resume I'm sorry he confessed he never
worked directly for Goldman Sachs and
Citigroup which he claimed to have done
saying it was a quote poor choice of
words that he worked for link Bridge
which did business with those companies
all right a little bit different he says
he stated it poorly
um he admitted he never actually
graduated from any college even though
he said I graduated from Baruch College
in 2010. I didn't graduate from any
institution of Higher Learning I'm
embarrassed and sorry for having
embellished my resume I own up to that
we do stupid things in life it's not
really embellishing to say I graduated
from a college I didn't graduate from
it's a lie it's a lie now on the issue
of being Jewish
sent the article says Santos was also
accused of lying about his family
history saying on his campaign website
his mother was Jewish and his
grandparents escaped the Nazis during
World War II remember no evidence exists
to back that up
Santos now says he's quote clearly
Catholic but claimed his grandmother
told stories about being Jewish and
later converting to Catholicism Santo
said I never claimed to be Jewish I said
I was Jew hyphen ish
[Laughter]
oh boy he argues technically none of
this is a crime that's what he's going
with
I'm not a criminal not here not abroad
in any jurisdiction in the world have I
ever committed any cries right to get
down to the nitty-gritty I'm not a fraud
I like that the knit and gritty not the
nitty-gritty to get down to the knit and
the gritty beautiful I'm not a
Criminal Who defrauded the entire
country and made up this fictitional
character in Rancor it is fictitional
and fictitious and it is a fiction
the knit and gritty of the fictitional
character is really coming to light
Congress I've been around a long time I
mean a lot of people know me they know
who I am they've done business dealings
with me I'm not gonna make excuses for
this but he kind of is a lot of people
overstate in their resumes or
um twist a little bit or ingrangiate
themselves oh my God ingrangiate dear
God if he said ingratiate it would not
make sense but in Grand it's all this
guy doesn't know what's going on now I'm
actually learning much more about this
so psychological explanations for this
not from me but for mental health
experts about why people do this why do
people do this one possibility they just
have a tendency towards pathological
lying it's almost like a reflex they
have a it's a compulsion it's a
compulsion to just lie often for no
apparent reason I've told the story of
someone I knew when I was in high school
and they said my my glasses are 500 this
was a very long time ago nobody had 500
just prescription glasses my glasses
were 500 because they're special I don't
even care about your glasses why are you
lying about that it doesn't make any
sense I don't care one way or the other
right all right it's a compulsion they
can't control it and often it comes with
a lack of remorse or a lack of feeling
of guilt when you do it which is sort of
what we're seeing here
um another possibility
is that it's a need for attention and
validation and so it it's not a
compulsion to lie it's this desire to be
validated by people to be seen as good
to be seen as smart and all these
different things and it can also be just
as simple as it was calculated because
he thought it would help him win he he
realized his actual record wasn't very
good uh and so he made it up because he
thought it would help him win which by
the way it appears to have helped he
should resign uh he's not going to
here's a really funny clip by the way
where Kevin McCarthy touts we have so
many Jewish people joining us and he
mentions George Santos it's great but I
really want to talk about
who's the makeup of this new majority
you heard from some of all already
you know with Max Miller in Ohio George
Santos in New York and you had David
kustoff from Tennessee get reelected
he introduced him yeah do you realize we
have the largest Republican Jewish
caucus more than 24 years very very very
exciting of course for the Republican
party so Santos should resign you'd be
fired from any job for doing this and
his argument that what he did wasn't a
crime is very very shaky there's
actually a longer interview that Santos
did it's a total softball
I don't want to play the whole thing for
you so we're going through it we're
going to pull out the most interesting
clips and we'll look at them tomorrow
let's face it the holiday season can be
a stressful time for anyone even a
stressor on relationships in-laws
dividing time mismatched expectations
around gifts our sponsor paired is the
app that makes it easy to maintain a
feeling of connection with your partner
during this crazy time of year you and
your partner download the app you pair
together an everyday paired gives the
two of you questions or quizzes games to
have fun stay emotionally connected
deepen your conversations and all of the
exercises were developed by academic
psychologists and expert relationship
therapists as well my girlfriend and I
have been using paired quite a bit
lately it's fun especially with the baby
these days it's more important than ever
for us to find quality time and parrot
is really the perfect way to spark that
with funny moments meaningful
conversation stations and we can use
paired on the go don't let end of year
stressors get in the way of you and your
partner enjoying some connecting paired
makes it simple and giving your
significant other a paired subscription
is a great last minute holiday gift head
over to paired.com Pacman for a seven
day free trial and 25 off a subscription
the link is down below